the Google Cloud speech API enables easy
integration of Google speech recognition
technologies into developer applications
the speech API allows you to send audio
and receive a text transcription from
the service using the Google Cloud
speech API you can generate captions
from a video file an audio recording or
a live situation the speech API supports
both synchronous and asynchronous speech
to text transcription over on quick labs
you'll be diving into the Google cloud
speech API in just 15 minutes you'll
create an API key create a speech API
request and call the speech API request
like with all of our quick labs you'll
have all the resources you need to work
on the lab there are many applications
for this technology and we'd love to
hear what you're doing with it let us
know what you're up to in the comments
below as you may already know this
self-paced lab is part of the baseline
data ml and AI quest on quick labs
completing all the labs in the quest
earns you this badge to recognize your
new skills